overseas now in the war in Ukraine where
Russia has fired still more missiles
more drones overnight causing fresh
damage in Ukrainian cities including
this Hospital in Dinuba Ukrainian
President zlinski says one person was
killed there but meanwhile we are
learning more about recent attacks
inside Russia claimed by Russian groups
that oppose President Vladimir Putin
Deborah Paddock got a rare on the record
comment from one of these shadowy
organizations
from the car bombs and blasts in Moscow
killing vocal Advocates of the invasion
of Ukraine
to the most recent cross-border raids
inside Russia's bilge region there is
clear evidence of armed resistance to
Vladimir Putin's War
the anti-kremlin fighters Behind these
attacks are a loose collection of
disparate groups with Divergent
political views and ideologies but
United by one common goal
um
to ensure the collapse of the Russian
regime as quickly as possible this Mast
anti-putin gunman told us CBS News sent
written questions to our partisan group
claiming to be operating on Russian soil
the fighters heavily disguised say they
derail the train in briansk earlier this
month their most successful action to
date
and claim this footage shows them
setting off an explosion and attacking a
Russian electrical substation
we're destroying military targets and
support infrastructure the spokesman
said like power stations and railway
lines
CBS News cannot independently verify the
group's claims this week's audacious
attacks inside Bill garage were launched
by two other partisan organizations the
Russian volunteer Corps and the free
Russia Legion okay fresh from their raid
they held a Brazen media conference near
the Russian Border in the east of
Ukraine the commander of the volunteer
Corps Denise kapustin known for his
Ultra right-wing leanings threatened
more attacks phase one we consider it a
successful phase it's over now but the
operation is ongoing that's what I can
say for now
he added that no American military
equipment was used in the attack while
the masked men we spoke to so they could
get any weapon they needed from a huge
black market that's Arisen as a result
of Putin's War Nancy
remarkable reporting Deborah patta in
Ukraine thank you